de 200 días de huelga de hambre y una
promesa no beber más agua es la medida
que tomará el activista egipcio a la App
del fatá puesto en prisión por
supuestamente divulgar noticias falsas
con la apertura de puertas de la 27 he
tomado la decisión de escalar en un
momento que considero adecuado para mi
lucha por mi libertad y la libertad de
los prisioneros de un conflicto en el
que no participan o del que están
tratando de salir
no es la primera vez se encuentra tras
las rejas el activista fue una de las
caras más conocidas de la primavera
árabe en Egipto en 2011 fue detenido
durante más de dos meses y luego puesto
en libertad En ese entonces hablaba de
las duras condiciones en las que vivían
los prisioneros
la situación allí es muy dura y quiénes
son encerrados por asesinatos son
Víctimas de tortura con electricidad o
suspensión
tras defender la democracia el líder
ahora apunta a la otra cara de la moneda
de la Cumbre por el medio ambiente la
represión a los activistas por parte del
gobierno de abdelfatá al Sisi una
problemática que señalaba human right
watch en septiembre el gobierno de
egipcio ha impuesto obstáculos
arbitrarios a la financiación la
investigación y el registro que han
debilitado a los grupos ecologistas
locales obligando a algunos activistas a
exiliarse y a otros a alejarse de
trabajos importantes
el caso de abdelfata había llegado
incluso a las manos de Boris Johnson al
tener ciudadanía británica el ex Primer
Ministro había hablado de su caso con el
Sisi ahora la confirmación de Richie
sunat desistirá a la Cumbre podría poner
su caso en la agenda del nuevo Premier
[Aplausos]